welcome to the man of recaps this is
moon night meet steven grant a
mild-mannered english chap who works the
gift shop at the egyptian museum he has
a normal boring life where his best
friends are the living statue guy his
mom's voicemail and his one thinned
goldfish but he's been sleepwalking
lately so he chains himself up every
night so he can't go anywhere and
tonight it doesn't work he wakes up in a
random european village with a
mysterious egyptian scarab in his pocket
and people shooting at him this whole
village it seems is kind of a cult led
by this man arthur harrow and he wants
his scarab back but stephen's having a
hard time giving it to him and now
what's this steven blacks out and when
he comes too he's beat up all these guys
he escapes these guys in a hilarious
non-action scene where he keeps blacking
out for apparently the cool parts
stephen wakes up was it all a dream but
at night at the museum he's attacked by
a jackal monster what he hides in the
bathroom where his reflection talks to
him in an american accent stephen give
me the body yes steven has an alternate
personality that's not just a normal
badass but a superhero named moon knight
the next day steven does some digging
and finds out his alternate personality
is mark spector an american mercenary
they get to talking and it's like hey
stephen i wanted to protect you from
this but i'm the avatar of the egyptian
god consu god of the moon and fist of
justice and now stephen meets another
friend of marx this mysterious girl
layla she's a super cool egypt
archaeologist adventurer type and
steven's head over heels but turns out
she's married to mark and they're
currently divorcing he's trying to
protect her from all this indeed right
away steven's captured by harrow who's
like hey we got off on the wrong foot
let me start again see he was conscious
previous avatar but he serves a new
master now the egyptian god ahmet who
judges people before they've committed
evil and punishes them ahead of time the
scarab leads to ahmed's tomb he wants to
release her and judge the whole world
but steven's like yo you can't punish
people before their crimes you and layla
try to escape so harrow summons another
jacla monster and it's like yo we need
mark to summon the suit but for now
they're stuck with steven so he summons
the suit a superfly white suit but not
the one they normally wear steven does
his best to fight this jackal but pretty
soon he gives control to mark and yeah
moon knights here make short work of
this thing but harrow got the scarab so
we're going to egypt to stop him so mark
and steven have to learn to work
together stephen makes him promise no
more killing but after one fight they
wake up having murdered all these
henchmen it's like yo that wasn't me so
watch out for a third personality but
they can't find harrow so they go to
this black market artifact dealer who's
got a sarcophagus with a different map
to almost do but things go bad so moon
knight's here and yeah oh he throws
things yeah he's an awesome fighter but
it's difficult because steven keeps
taking over like hey guys let's stop
with all the violence so to get the star
map and stephen consho worked together
to change the night's sky to the night
it was when it was made but countries on
probation right now with the other
egyptian gods because earlier they had a
big trial where it's like hey hero's
trying to release ahmet and he was like
no i'm not and the other gods were like
well that's good enough for me so for
messing with the nice guy the other gods
all in prison concho in stone so now our
heroes have to stop harrow with no moon
knight powers and now as layla's gotten
to know stephen they've kind of been
flirting and they have a super awkward
first kiss which mark does not
appreciate stephen kissing his wife but
now they do some classic tomb raiding
and find dominant statue hey we got it
before harrow of course hero was waiting
for them to get it so now he can take it
from them and he shoots some no moon
knight healing powers mark and steven
really dying but now mark wakes up in a
mental hospital where harrow is his
doctor and it's like yeah man sorry
you're crazier than you thought this
whole moon night thing is in your head
as mark tries to escape he finds steven
in his own body so these two get to hug
it out and wait who's this now it's a
hippopotamus girl yeah that's pretty
crazy and mark does keep flashing back
to the hospital it's left ambiguous
whether it's real or in his head
hippolady is another egyptian god who
guides travelers to the underworld and
yeah they're on a big boat through the
sand dunes but to be allowed in they
judge their hearts have to balance the
scales by going through each other's
memories so mark spector had a happy
family until one day he and his brother
were playing in the cave during the rain
and his brother drowned and his mom
blamed little mark which is super uncool
and she never let it go for years always
hated him and so this trauma of living
with an abusive mother gave birth to
stephen the alternate personality who
was blissfully unaware and thought his
mom still loved him it's a big emotional
episode give oscar isaac all the awards
but in the end it's like hey man it's
not your fault but their skills still
aren't balanced so the sand people are
coming to drag them down and they're
fighting them together but oh steven off
the boat he's trapped in the sands of
purgatory while mark gets to go to the
field of reeds back in the world of
living harrow's got dominant statue and
he releases her whoa crocodile god and
so they begin their evil plan of
prejudging all the souls in the world
but in the afterlife mark's not gonna
leave steven he goes back for him and
it's the end of frozen where they love
each other and boom it unfreezes them
and the other egyptian gods are like yo
you guys gotta get back up there and
stop bomb it so as they come back to
life layla frees konchu and boom moon
knight is reborn konchu launches him up
there and he's not flying he's pulling a
buzz lightyear just falling with style
and layla became the avatar of hippo
goddess boom she's a superhero too and
even steven's getting in on the fight
too now he and mark fully working
together changing personalities
mid-fight yeah in the end of course
hero's gonna win but what's this now
they both black out and wake up having
won the fight watch out for this third
personality so now they do the ancient
rituals seal amit inside harrow's body
conscious like yo you gotta kill him
before they do evil again and it's like
wait a minute now you sound a lot like
amit they can't hurt anyone anymore
we're not gonna kill him and earlier
mark and steven made the deal this would
be their last mission so they're
released from their service says moon
knight so the world is saved and mark
and steven new best friends happily
sharing their body but what's this now
someone grabs harrow and throws him in
the back of a limo for a meeting with
konchu who's taken style tips from
steven the deal to release them did not
include their third personality jake
lockley he speaks spanish and he has no
problem killing in cold blood and that's
where moon knight comes to an end
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies
[Music]